hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for the monday morning
podcast for monday
uh march 15th what's going on how
oh yeah how's it going oh billy freckles
jamming too much into one friggin day
knocking out the podcast here and then
i'm gonna go run out and do a spot
because i got that um i got that that
tour coming up
that one-shot tour of uh i'm doing from
somebody's [ __ ] garage
out here in california that's going to
be broadcasted
to new zealand in australia i'm very
excited about that but i'm also very
excited to not bomb on it so i have to
make sure i do a bunch of spots
and get ready for the thing and overall
it's been a positive response that this
is what i'm doing but still there's
always like negative people like girl
why don't you make it available for
[ __ ] everybody
it's just like do you really mean
that's isn't that why don't that's not
what you're saying what you're really
saying is why don't you make it
available for me because you wouldn't
give a [ __ ] if somebody in sri lanka
it's one of my favorite [ __ ] just
countries to pull out of nowhere
um you don't give a [ __ ] whether they
can see the show or not do you
it's always somebody who's got a [ __ ]
complaint and coming from someone who
complains for a living you know
i probably got a lot of nerf whatever
i'm getting ready to do this so i'm
going to do a spot tonight
and uh i got some [ __ ] that i want to
work out um
i'm [ __ ] tired because they did the
stupid um
was the time change thing [ __ ] moves
forward
it's just the worst i already woke up
early because i had a bunch of [ __ ] i
had to do today but i knocked everything
out everything's on the other side
i'm very happy about that the celtics
did their thing against houston beat the
[ __ ] out of them the way they should
have like 130 to [ __ ] i don't know
108 or something like that
dropped 130 points on him i missed the
game i'm very happy about that
uh went out on a date with my lovely
wife on
saturday night say dude why don't you
come over and say
um we went out got some dinner dinner
and uh you know that's the big thing now
you can eat outside
he need outside as more and more people
are getting vaccinated i just i love all
the [ __ ] misinformation out there man
jesus christ
everybody just flying around do you know
i'm all over the map right now sorry
people i had a long [ __ ] day
um i got to make sure i don't forget to
say this but uh
marvin hagler marvelous marvin hanger
hagler unfortunately passed away and
um he
he was my favorite boxer when i was
growing up
and i absolutely loved that middleweight
division
um hagler hearns duran
and leonard i mean you just you had to
be there
then they had alexis arguelle they had
all of these other divisions just with
all these
champs you know what i mean it was
pre-tyson
so larry holmes was the heavyweight
champ and you know
as much as he was knocking dudes out
like people came in you're like what's
going to happen here is he going to win
is he going to lose it wasn't like when
tyson came in here
tyson's going to [ __ ] kill him but
that middleweight division
and they all fought each other you know
a lot of them multiple times i know uh
uh leonard fought duran twice leonard
fought [ __ ]
hearns twice um
fought hagler once and hagler retired
after that but like marvin hagler was
just
he was just my favorite you know he was
out of brockton massachusetts and uh
i love the shaved head i just thought he
was a badass you know
and um i was so upset that he passed
away only 66 years old
and um the greatest fight
that i saw in the 80s was him versus uh
tommy hearns i'll never forget that i
believe there was a kid i went to high
school with
that went to that fight um
and it was just people were just
standing up
for was it two and a half rounds got
into round three and then that was it
and uh what i loved about tommy hearns
was
he wanted to mix it up he was
this incredible fighter where he was so
much taller
so he really could have stayed on the
outside if he wanted to
and one of the most brutal knockouts i
ever [ __ ] saw was when hearns knocked
out durant jesus
christ i thought he [ __ ] killed he
hit him and duran just went s
straight down um
but you could kind of draw him into a
fight and i felt like uh
that's what hagler did that i know i did
just i just talked about this or maybe i
talked about it on
the tyson podcast or whatever but um
rest in peace to him man
um an absolute
just a champ total class act
and um i also thought the way that he
left he never he never came back
you know came back years later and you
had to watch some you know
you know when somebody when fighters
come back and they're too [ __ ] old
and you're just like oh man you know
nobody likes seeing that and you don't
want to see
somebody you love come back and take a
beating his last fight was an epic fight
um i loved him too much to be uh
not biased on it i mean i thought he won
it um
but it was a super super close fight and
um i don't know i really think in a lot
of ways that
the judges maybe were like well if we
give it to leonard
hagler's going to want a rematch and we
can all get [ __ ] paid again
the filthy game of boxing who knows but
um
so anyways he he passed away and i was
reading all these great comments about
him and then some [ __ ] idiots like oh
he
he took the vaccine that's why he died
like literally everything
is about that [ __ ] now and somebody told
me you know i'm gonna try to get the
shot tomorrow the first one right and
the
somebody said the uh the ceo of pfizer
hasn't [ __ ] taken it yet and then i
look it up going oh because now i got
nervous and i look it up it's like yeah
we don't want to jump the line
all right now look i'm a conspiracy
theorist too but like
um if you really think that they're to
try to kill all of us with this
just think about that just think about
that and then they're going to be alive
and there's going to be what six billion
dead bodies
like the [ __ ] disease that that who's
going to bury all of them you think
these [ __ ]
illuminati rich people know how to drive
a bulldozer and
start digging [ __ ] holes all right
as much as they don't like us they need
us alive to do all the [ __ ] that they
don't want to do so i don't think they
would just randomly just start
killing people um
and i'm not buying i don't buy in any of
these stupid [ __ ]
internet poor [ __ ] anymore anything on
the [ __ ] internet can just
i don't i don't give a [ __ ] anymore
right i don't give a [ __ ] so i'm gonna
do it i'll be the guinea pig for you
guys
so um anyway i go out with my my lovely
wife
on saturday night right and uh you know
we're sitting
out on the street went to this place
right off on
ventura boulevard um
which really doesn't mean anything in
l.a because all of the streets just go
for [ __ ] nine zillion miles and uh
like you can get on you can get off of
your street get on the highway
and then drive 20 miles get off the
highway
and all of a sudden cross and be like oh
they got yeah they got a mainstream down
here too
it's the same one it's [ __ ]
long long ass [ __ ] roads out here so
anyway we're on
off at ventura boulevard and it was uh
saturday night so there was these
goddamn punk kids
out there with their loud cars jesus
christ
there is a [ __ ] epidemic epidemic of
[ __ ] cars that are not that
fast with really loud exhausts
i was on the highway the other night
this [ __ ] guy in like a dodge
charger or something the [ __ ] noise
this guy was making and i was driving 61
miles an hour because i kept looking
down
he went by me yeah
looked like he was going 68 and i could
hear his car
and see his car for like another three
minutes
i just kept laughing to my wife going
he's right there that car making all
that noise
the one that went by that sounded like a
[ __ ] you know an
f-18 and i'm supposed to be like wow you
got a fast car sorry i can still see you
um i don't know what that is about
i when i was a kid if a car was like
loud it meant it had horsepower and it
would go
flying by and it would scare the [ __ ]
out of you and then you're like where
the hell is it
now it's just i don't know they have
these um
they make they make these i don't know
these exhaust systems make it sound like
your car is fast
so we were um
we were sitting outside to eat and these
[ __ ] kids just kept coming by yeah
doctor flying by
it was kind of funny because it was
really [ __ ] up the meal and that
really is
you know it's what you get when you eat
outside so i definitely saw the humor in
it
but uh i saw the humor but i did not see
the speed
so any of you youngsters out there want
to tell me what what is that about let
me look that [ __ ] up right now there's
something going on
all right let me see here right now okay
first of all here's this
this the pfizer unsee pfizer ceo albert
borla said he hasn't received his
company's covet vaccine shot yet
telling cnbc that he and the other
executives will not
cut the line the vaccine which fizer
developed in partnership with the
german-based
bio end tech is the first to be
authorized for emergency use
uh to prevent covert 19. um he hasn't
got the back seen yet
bill gates fires are playing i'm sure if
i looked at all the comments
everybody has figured it out from their
[ __ ] one-bedroom apartment but i'm
not gonna read those things i'm gonna
i'm gonna get it
[ __ ] it all right [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it because if they are trying to
kill everybody uh i'm going to be the
first in line for them to do it because
i don't want to be like i don't live in
the world after that
and then you got to sit there and act
like it didn't happen
and all rights have been taken away
want are you having your own thoughts
maybe you need the vaccine you need to
be re-educated
um all right does a
loud exhaust
mean it's faster
a lot of exhausts can sometimes increase
engine power
your car may sound nicer this is
subjective by the way but louder
exhausts
don't necessarily translate into more
power yeah that's that's what i'm seeing
out there
i mean i would think that yeah
horsepower does you know i've never
understood how
getting a better exhaust system i've
read up on it i just still don't get it
i don't understand how
it it can give you a couple extra horses
but um
at the end of the day i always thought
it was about the engine and then [ __ ]
you know power to weight ratio was the
big thing and i know that the exhaust
system is like a part of it but i got to
tell you the amount of
loud ass [ __ ] cars that are going
nowhere [ __ ] nowhere um
i wonder what those because there is
something like uh i do find fascinated
about that [ __ ] because what i've really
learned about myself is i am
a i'm an introvert
um despite my job i like when i just
you know [ __ ] off that's my you know
that [ __ ] off it's just sort of like i i
like being alone
and when i go in some place i don't need
everybody to know that i'm there so when
i see extroverts i find them
fascinating and the only thing better
than one extrovert is a bunch of them
all trying to outdo each other so they
all have these loud cars so you just sit
there looking at it
and i always just wonder what do they
think that everybody else is thinking
do they think like wow man that guy is
cool because what always ends up
happening
is when they after they go by is
everybody just
looks and just laughs like
and how [ __ ] stupid it is so anyway
we were sitting there
and um you know it's the usual day you
go on with the woman you know once
you're in a relationship
um oh my god what's his face did a
[ __ ] hilarious bit on this
uh uh brett ernst did a bit on this and
i i
lived his bit where when you sit down
with the woman
and they do this thing where they go you
know i can't decide
if between the burger
or the fish it's like i love both of
them i just can't decide
what are you gonna get well obviously
i'm gonna order one of those two things
whatever you don't get
and you know
and then afterwards she's like how'd you
like the fish i was like i didn't
you know i just didn't i didn't i wasn't
into it the burger was all right
and she was just like i was like but you
know
you know i know you want to both those
side orders just you didn't have to do
that
it's like i know i don't i know i don't
but happy wife
happy life
that's so i do it i just
[ __ ] do i know i don't have to but i
do enough
other [ __ ] that causes [ __ ]
bumps in the road right like i i had
this [ __ ]
gig that i had to do this weekend
and i just had a lot of anxiety i ended
up having fun on the gig but it's just
like you know it's just
it's one of those things that not
necessarily i ever thought i would be
doing
i didn't think that that was a part of
show business that i would be in and i
just always find that when i do gigs
like that
those are the gigs where i end up
nowadays you end up you know
you know it's just i don't know it's
just stupid it's just
i don't i don't understand it i don't
understand
um i guess i get it i just don't
why everybody [ __ ] tolerates it i i
don't want to get into it i don't get it
to it but i just knew i knew what the
[ __ ] i was walking into
so i was just going like oh jesus christ
what what what's
what the [ __ ] gonna happen on this one
just one of those gigs right so i was
kind of half there
so i figured if i ordered both things
that she wanted
my weird mood would sort of save the
dinner which it didn't
and then to add to it yeah they said
that [ __ ] cars driving by
i saw one of them was [ __ ] hilarious
this [ __ ]
weak-ass car and it actually had a dent
in the rear quarter panel
so more of the exhaust was showing and
where the noise was was right where the
dent was which was funny too because i
was picturing
him making all this noise and then some
old guy going away [ __ ] car and
kicking it right there
um speaking of which i had my truck
worked on i've been having this power
steering leak and uh we thought we fixed
it
uh i can't say we the guy did did a
[ __ ] great job i got new shocks on it
man it was running great
and i looked under i was all excited to
see it bone dry under my truck and then
there was just a one little leak
so you might have to replace something
else but it was kind of cool though
there was some sort of bearings or
something like that and the steering
column i don't i don't know it's like
part of the steering uh what do they
call it the assembly
and uh it was just cool he was holding
them showing me that they were worn out
and all i could just think is like
because my truck is 53 years old this
month
because i looked at the vin number it
was put together in toronto ontario
in march of 1968 right so i was like
i was just looking at him the same way i
was looking at that sewer pipe
from the front of my house that was put
in you know 100 [ __ ] years ago almost
just i love seeing that [ __ ] like
somebody put that together
you know a month before
martin luther king and robert kennedy
when somebody put that in that was right
at the end that's how [ __ ] long ago
that was
and there it is he's holding it in his
hand like it's like a time capsule i
really think that that shit's cool
i was also bummed out that i didn't end
up [ __ ] manning up and changing the
shocks myself because i don't even i
have such an old truck like
it doesn't have any struts or anything
like that and it's always just literally
a you know a bolt on top and on the
bottom but i don't have jack stands
and [ __ ] or the [ __ ] time to do all
of that stuff but i've
that was one of those ones where i was
just like
[Music]
never worked on a suspension i kind of
psyched myself out i'm like what about
that spring doesn't the spring come
flying off if you take off the shock
or does it not there's a whole trick to
that thing and if that thing comes
flying out i could take your [ __ ]
head off or something i was just like
all right you know what
i think i'm just gonna stick to being a
goddamn comedian here
so but um
i've been having that leak for a while
so it was fun for a moment before i
realized the leak was still going but
we're going to take care of it this week
or
this guy's going to take care i found a
great mechanic out here so i'm very
excited about that
um so what do you think those loud car
kids are going to do someday when just
like
electric cars they just get sick
of losing to beta people all the loud
alphas are sick of losing debate of
people in their [ __ ]
little leg like as loud as those cars
are
that little [ __ ] ice cube looking car
that bmw
makes do you know that's the fastest
they car last i checked
the fastest car they have zero to 60
is that car then after that it becomes
the six series but it's just [ __ ]
hilarious to me
that those all those cars make all of
that [ __ ] noise and there's this
little ice cube
like a picnic basket in the back um
it really is if you're looking for
[ __ ] speed i mean that
really is where it's at now i don't know
about
top end they always talk about well
one's passed a certain there's always
some ridiculous number two
well you know once past 85 [ __ ] blah
blah blah it's like where the [ __ ]
you're on the road
i mean i guess if you go out to a track
that makes sense
but um i don't know i find all that [ __ ]
fascinating and i do know
that f1 and um moto gp are starting
soon so i am getting excited about that
but i am going down the [ __ ] rabbit
hole
right now um i've kind of let my french
studies
slide i'm letting you know haven't been
playing too much drums
and i'm just locking in to uh
being able to um get this instrument
stuff and i've been on the simulator
i've been doing holding patterns and
the la you know yesterday i did my first
approach
which is i'm not going to bore you with
everything but it's [ __ ] wild
where you're just using all of these
vors using two vors i think at the same
time
and flying the radial in whatever the
[ __ ] terminology is i'm learning all
of this stuff
and as you get
to each level of air just going down
another 2 000 feet and then when you
come out of the clouds and there's the
[ __ ] runway it's the greatest feeling
ever
it's [ __ ] amazing and it's all
starting to make sense so i'm very
excited about that
um i've just been having problems with
my x-plane 11 that i've been using i
need to uh recalibrate the uh
whatever the [ __ ] you call it the
throttle and all of that [ __ ] i gotta
have some nerd come over here and help
me
out because i cannot figure out how to
uh
use the hsi if anybody knows how to do
that or has like a [ __ ]
you know i'm trying to track vors and do
stuff like that and do holding patterns
if anybody's a pilot knows how to do
that
on the x-plane 11 or has a demonstration
video because i can't find one
um i would appreciate that all right and
with that
let's do um let's do a little bit of the
advertising here
um oh look oh wait wait before i get
into that i've been watching more
another philip seymour hoffman movie
which
uh i'm having a hard time getting
through because
it is just gut-wrenching to watch what
this character's doing uh it's called
owning mahoney i don't know if i talked
about this yet
but good lord i'm like i'm always such a
huge
philip seymour hoffman fan but now that
i'm really just sort of
i can't believe how many movies he did i
thought i saw most of his work i barely
saw any of it
he was just so [ __ ] great um
and i was so satisfied with what i saw i
felt like i had seen
all of his stuff and um but the
character said he
i can tell you this if he's starring in
a movie
whatever character he's playing it is
gonna be a bumpy [ __ ] ride
um i'm a half hour into this movie
and i've had to watch it in 10 minute
increments because i just watched that
love liza movie
and it's just like oh god i i don't know
if i can watch him do this another one
of these guys man like just
watching somebody just so [ __ ] up
their life
um and the way he plays it it's just so
[ __ ] real
um you gotta look away that like
you know snl did that whole bit about uh
women late at night watching like true
crime
and my wife sent me that thought it was
the funniest [ __ ] thing because
that's what she does the other night
oh my god she had me watching this
[ __ ] thing where this guy
like he had a side chick
and he convinced the side chick to kill
his wife and then
she was so [ __ ] enamored with him
she actually got arrested
and he was still able to maintain
control over her that she went to
jail and he kept writing her letters
saying that she was going to get out
and blah blah blah she just kept
believing him
until finally she just woke up 10 years
into a sentence like what in the [ __ ]
and eventually they got this guy but
um it was so [ __ ] disturbing
to watch right before you go to bed it's
just like can we just like watch
a sports center like back in the day and
i would sit there
you can always tell i think why not tell
i mean you know because you're watching
the show but like
i always love like when when the husband
is involved with the missing woman
when they do that [ __ ] tv interview
just the lack of sadness
in their eyes and in their face going
well you know
she has been missing since friday and we
are all very concerned we just want to
get her back
and just looking at you just like all
right that guy's this guy's somehow
connected
he is not even remotely emotionally
attached to what the [ __ ] he's saying
but then party is like oh my god you
know going through god forbid going
through something like that like
how how are you emotionally attached to
anything you must just be [ __ ]
stunned
and then the reporter shows up it's got
to be so surreal
i don't know but i will tell you there's
been a few times i've been on the
watching the local news and they
interview somebody and i've said to my
wife going i think that person has
something to do with it
and i've never been right so don't
listen to me all right let's do some
reads here for the week
for the week here starting over again oh
my god it's st
patrick's day everybody uh my bookie
march is here and the madness
has finally begun shoot your shot to
score big
on the non-stop action with my bookie
select the winners from 63 tournament
games in the my bookie bracket contest
for a chance at ten thousand dollars in
cash prizes
and it's only a dollar to enter only a
dollar
that's the price of a cheeseburger and
if you really want to put your money
where your mouth is
they got a hundred thousand dollar
contest and that's only
ten bucks to enter jesus christ what uh
what is that ten dollars to enter that's
that's a
what kind of return is that on your
money
huh ten thousand percent is that what
that is
yeah ten thousand percent uh it doesn't
matter whether
you're filling out multiple brackets
betting the national championship winner
or simply looking for a player and game
props
my bookie has you covered sign up today
at mybookie.ag
and use promo code burr to secure a
deposit bonus up to
one thousand dollars and make sure you
use my promo code
code sorry so they know i hooked you up
that's my bookie.ag
promo code bird to claim your first
deposit bonus college ball
nba and nhl no matter the sport no
matter the minute
my bookie puts the action in your hands
with in-game
live betting and with choice and with
the choice
with choice from thousands of lines and
odds you can turn any game day
into a payday bet anything anytime
anywhere at my
bookie all right movement everybody
mvmt in a tiny apartment in southern
california
two college dropouts teamed up to create
a watch company that broke
all the rules with fair prices
unexpected colors what is that
and clean original designs mvmt
pronounced
movement grew into one of the fastest
growing watch brands
shipping to over 160 uh countries across
the globe
now movement has expanded into blue
light glasses i got to get a [ __ ]
pair of these
that protect your eyes from screens uh
minimalist
jewelry and oh
oh they also make minimalist jurors true
i thought the blue light glasses protect
you from screens
and minimalist jewelry i'm like what the
[ __ ] kind of
glow is that [ __ ] giving off uh and more
style
essentials that don't break the bank all
designed out of their california
headquarters movement watchers have the
look and quality of a 400
to 500 watch while you're paying uh
for at a department store what movement
watches have the look and quality of a
to 500 watch you're paying for at a
department store but
cost a fraction of the price because
they were built online
and own their process from start to
finish
you get a beautiful watch ship right to
your door for free
and if you don't love it you can ship it
right back for free
um i gotta spend all day in front of my
computer and my ever scroll blue light
fiberglasses
are a game changer well that's what i'm
supposed to say did they send me some
i know they're gonna be send me some
please um it really helps with eye
strain and poor sleeping patterns
and evidently i love the modern style of
the frames this is me in the future
everybody
um if you want to elevate your look with
style with a style that doesn't break
the bank then join the movement
and get 15 off today with free shipping
and free returns by going to
mvmt.comburr
again that's mvmt.com
um roman
squeaky doors clogged sinks finicky
engines when things break around the
house
you can take care of it however when
something's off in the bedroom
you just you just try not to think about
it
come on man what are you waiting for
take care of it
go to getroman.com burn now and make
your dick get back in the [ __ ] game
does your dick have a towel around its
neck just riding the bench
there's only three minutes left in the
game uh with roman
you can get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for erectile dysfunction
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home
a u.s licensed health care professional
will work with you
to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate it ships to
you for free
with two-day shipping the whole process
is straightforward and discreet
getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com
and complete an online visit take care
of your erectile dysfunction
without leaving your home complete an
online visit today to connect with the
health care professional and take care
of it
go to get roman.com now and you get 15
off your first month it's really time to
take care of your ed
and remember get started today and
you'll save 15
on your first order of erectile
dysfunction treatment
roman is spelt r-o-m-a-n for people out
there as dumb as me
all right simply safe everyone
if you have 30 minutes you never have to
worry about a break-in at home ever
again
um that is how quick and easy it is well
what the [ __ ] what if somebody doesn't
give a [ __ ] that you got a camera
they're just going for broke you know at
least you know they're coming right
i don't know that is how quick and easy
it is to set up a security system from
simply safe
it's the kind of thing that's so easy to
do you can do it during a netflix binge
watching the game or listening to a
certain podcast oh they're talking about
me
simply safe isn't is incredibly easy to
customize for your home just go to
simplysafe.com
you can easily choose the exact sensors
you need or get help from one of their
experts
uh it'll get to your house in about a
week which means by this time next week
and
you and your whole family can go to bed
knowing your home is being guarded it's
easy to assume everyone in the house
already feels safe but they might but
they might not and it's worthwhile to
talk about it and simply safe is a small
easy step to make sure
everyone feels safe at home go to
simplysafe.com today to customize your
system and get a free security camera uh
you also get a 60 day risk free trial so
there's nothing to lose that's simply
safe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i s-a-f-e um
oh i almost forgot to tell you guys i i
i
got a chance to fly let me see i think
it's a md 600
the notar yeah
i got to go up and take a spin in one of
those things that was my dream
come true i want to thank the people
involved that allowed that to happen
um i just did a quick you know somebody
took me up and let me take the controls
for like you know a little bit
just to check it out uh that's like the
one from um
magnum pi the updated version where it
has no tail rotor
it actually creates a vacuum it sucks
air into the tail
boom that then shoots down and then
there's like this thing that moves on
the back that controls the amount of air
coming out which controls the amount of
thrust
so rather than the tail rotor
you know adjusting the angle of attack
it's more the amount of uh air that's
coming out so that
really fascinates the hell out of me and
i never even asked him
um if that eliminates oh let me i
can answer it right now let's see this
is really a big aviation nerd thing
right now
does notar
eliminate lte
lte not working what the [ __ ]
no tar wait no tar
system it's not answering this for me
why
eliminate i don't have to write in the
capitals
come on man helicopter come on
um notar technology
anti-torque system eliminates all of the
mechanical problems you could possibly
have
the air is expelled through two slots
okay i know how it works but does that
loss of notar effectiveness well it
doesn't
a subreddit for helicopter industry
professional tuesday no no no no
i guess it doesn't
i guess it doesn't oh well lte's loss of
tail rotor effectiveness
um sorry all right let's get into some
questions here for the week
everybody um
best vibe music source what's up
big old billy [ __ ] tits
dude i'm [ __ ] crushing this diet by
the way
i am uh what is what is today march what
well i'm recording on the 14th today's
the 15th i've been
basically going veggie um the entire
time and then like once a week i have
like a [ __ ]
cheat meal that's it so when i went out
to that
restaurant with my wife i had a little
bit of fish and i had half of a
cheeseburger
but other than that i've just been doing
these uh
these bowls i've been making falafels
i've been doing all of this [ __ ] crap
i don't know what i'm doing i'm just
learning i just actually
bought some [ __ ] for a stir fry tomorrow
night
i figure the worst thing is going to
happen out of all of this is i'll just
have
all of these new meals that i can make
because i still think i'm going to eat
meat a little bit
i'm just trying to go the whole month
the best i can and
uh have had no booze obviously i'm done
with that [ __ ]
no cigars no nothing
um and uh this has been a long month i'm
not gonna lie to you
all right but as of tomorrow i think
we're almost halfway through it all
right best vibe
music source what's up old big
big old billy [ __ ] tits i'm 20 years
old and have been listening for a little
over a year while at work oh thank you
very much
i heard you mentioned you wanted to know
where to find good vibe music good man
i love it and i have a pretty good one
for you there's a 24
7 live stream called chilled cow
um that's such an internet name
you know it's always like that right
it's always like the [ __ ] i'm trying
to think of like a
[ __ ] internet name
velvet air you know it's always like
something that just doesn't exist
chilled cow on youtube
um
what am i on youtube and they have
different moods and vibes to choose
from they're like airwolf remember that
podcast network
airwolf like that was a perfect internet
[ __ ] name chilled cow
airwolf um okay they're very well known
and play
good beats to just listen to hope you
give them a shot thanks for giving me
and my dad something to talk and laugh
about we love the podcast that's awesome
i'm gonna check out chilled cow right
now i'm gonna have this in my computer
here
chilled cow
lo-fi hip-hop radio let's listen
let's have a quick little listen let's
take a sample
[Music]
wait this is the end here let's get to
the beginning
[Music]
wait a second
all right that part right there i like
[Music]
all right bill just relax everything's
gonna be okay
wait where'd the music go what the [ __ ]
i was just starting to relax
ah jesus christ now you have to hit
rewind this is not a little fine this is
[ __ ] pain in the ass
i just rewind
i see this is usually right now where
some fat chicks start singing
but i guess they don't is that lo-fi
music
i don't know all right i'll check it out
thank you though all right uh
greek vegan food dear billy the greek
uh greek food is underrated i love greek
food
i like greeks too man cool people when i
started eating plant-based
man for a short period of times this is
what got me through it lots of foods
don't feel like they're trying to
replace meat
yeah i hate that [ __ ] i hate that [ __ ]
just be a [ __ ] vegetable
stop trying to be something you're not
uh here's the link with some of them
okay so this one's www.greekboston.com
category vegan i love when you click on
it it's like open link
yeah well what the okay all right simple
greek roasted vegetables recipe for
vegan greek stuffed tomatoes those look
good
they were in season recipe for dole
maids i don't know how to say that
stuffed grape leaves you know there's a
great greek restaurant
out here the recipe for greek style
fried zucchini
that seems like if you want to be the
fat vegan uh
string beans anybody else want to try
this [ __ ]
greek style spinach rice
boiled greens i got to tell you guys
this is
mostly be like i don't eat that [ __ ]
[ __ ] i will tell you this
that my one cheat week uh cheap meal for
the week
after i eat it i just sit there like oh
my god
i always feel like i have a boot in my
[ __ ] stomach now
um all right
hoa information all right this is a home
i keep forgetting what's called home
organization this is like when your
[ __ ] neighbors all decide
hoa meaning
i can't remember this homeowner
association yeah this is like such a
douchey [ __ ] thing i get it
i get it if some degenerate gambler
moves in and he had a [ __ ] you know
hit on a couple of horses and he wants
to build a mcmansion i get it how you're
trying to keep
that [ __ ] from happening but
it also seems like it's a way to like
control people
or be s and be [ __ ] racist if you
wanted to i don't know it just seems
like uh they could go sideways
you know who comes up with an hoa
i just i'm so fascinated with
controlling people
like just you know just [ __ ] leave
people alone like this is
our neighborhood and we shouldn't have
to [ __ ] jaggy gag again right it's
always some
[ __ ] douche running that [ __ ] yap
whenever i talk to somebody like that i
i don't even hear them i just sit there
looking at their mouth
as the [ __ ] words are coming out
just thinking of everything that you
just you know
grabbing a roll of duct tape i always
picture that just
around the head real quick
all right uh love the show and stand up
thank you i just listened to the
march 8th podcast 2021
and wanted to give you some hoa info
homeowner associations can
foreclosure on your property for unpaid
dues
fines or fees who comes up with these
are they
do you have to own a home in that or is
this just some extension of the bank
um that caller needs to play ball with
the hoa
or move as it's not worth losing your
house
so they're a bunch of bullies that can
take your house unless everybody has the
same
group thought is that what it is
if they so you [ __ ] i own a house and
i if i don't think the way you [ __ ]
[ __ ] do
oh my god i love how people are worried
about big brother
what about this [ __ ] uh if they were to
foreclose the homeowner has the right in
most states to redeem the property
from the foreclosure there are state
guidelines that spell out the amount of
time
homeowners homeowners have for
redemption
if applicable best of luck to you and
your family and go [ __ ] yourself
well let's see here home owner
association
control i'm trying to try to find some
bad talk about
all right controlling neighbors don't
fight an hoa
alone
hoa responsibility for neighbor to
neighbor disputes
let me see hoas
are hoas
good
pros a good hoa is a pleasure to work
with and can increase your property
value
yeah this all seems like code for racist
and elitist and all of this [ __ ]
and you just know there's some [ __ ] that
[ __ ] put it together you just know it
khan's a bad hoa can make your life
miserable in other words
if you don't fit into what's going to
increase their property value what they
decided
um can make your life miserable and cost
you time and money a well-run homeowner
association can be a blessing important
could be a nightmare
are hoas racist
homeowners associations are still
keeping black americans out well that
didn't take long all right
[ __ ] [ __ ] i hate people
i [ __ ] really just i just don't like
you know
and i'm not singling out white people
here okay there's the same hoa
[ __ ] in every [ __ ] race they just
don't have the opportunity
you know to do it yet and then be
exposed
for the [ __ ] that they are um
all right buddha bulls hey billy bald
buddha bod
the bulls are called that called buddha
bolts because i think that's going to be
deemed offensive at some point the bulls
are called that because often in asia
buddhists are the vegetarians in society
uh if you're ordering food you wouldn't
say
you are a vegetarian you say you were
buddhist
to indicate you don't eat meat oh
love the show well i would think at some
point because the alliteration it's so
much fun to say
bootable it would come off as like
flippant but buddhists
they seem like the least offended
let me see this
have buddhists
i don't know how to spell it i know
there's an h in there i just
[ __ ] saw it wait b-u-d-d-a
buddhists ever
started a war
every other religion buddhism and
violence
but buddhism like the other great faiths
has not always lived up to its
principles oh jesus
there are numerous examples of buddhists
engaging in violence
and even war in the 12th century jesus
christ well
have they done anything what have you
who have you [ __ ] killed lately
all right i'll look that [ __ ] up later
uh
am i a dick weird neighbor issue
uh what does that say
billy butter uh loved the podcast
uh it helped me stay sane when i was
still working in the warehouse hope
you're doing well
i am doing i think i'm doing all right
uh so i kind of feel like a dick and
need some advice here am i a dick
or or reasonable i bought my first house
a year ago
and it turns out my neighbor is very
annoying
uh you know in new york city by the way
speaking of hoas they have like co-ops
and like the co-op can decide whether or
not you move into the building
i understand it you know because if you
you're gonna because you
bought there you're gonna live there and
if there's some loud
douche um that's gonna be a nightmare
but that's
i don't know it really opens the door to
all that other [ __ ] anyway since day one
um i already forgot what this guy said
uh i bought my first house a year ago
and it turns out my neighbor is very
annoying
since day one anytime he sees me or the
old lady outside or in the garage
he would come over with nothing to say
or ask really
there were times when he walked up the
long driver's driveway so silently
i wouldn't hear him until he was
standing in the garage door you
weird yeah you can't have that you
cannot have that and he walked over as
my girl was sitting in her car
waiting for it to warm up one day and
scared the [ __ ] out of her
i like my alone time in my garage doing
my thing so right before winner i had to
tell him to stay off my property
unless i invite him over exactly
good man he's friendly but seems kind of
off mentally yeah this guy's [ __ ]
weird dude
the second time i met him he asked me to
write a resume for him because
he found out i'm a teacher then he tried
inviting himself
inside saying he always lived next door
and wondered what the inside of our
house
looked like dude you have a [ __ ]
stage four creep
five being the highest number this guy's
like goomer on [ __ ] all
uh f is for family also when we were
moving in
he walked over and asked if there was an
upstairs to the house
very awkward he's in his 20s
and i feel bad because his parents
brought over some vegetables
over the summer but i am a dick but am i
a dick for telling him to stay on his
side of the fence
thanks can't wait uh to come to a show
when they start back up
and you're no not at all not at all
you did the [ __ ] right thing the last
thing you want to be is a nice person
in that situation you need to uh you
need to
um establish boundaries
and i hope that that guy is
um abiding by those things i hope
everybody in your house
understands that that guy is off and
uh it sucks that you live there but
there's no [ __ ] way i
i would ever walk out of my house
without having my head on a [ __ ]
you know swivel whatever the [ __ ] they
call keep your head on uh keep your head
on a swivel
um no you are not a dick at all
you are not a dick at all uh all right
girlfriend has
other boyfriend according to her grandpa
um hey oily bill
morrison hey you know what you know what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna cancel my [ __ ]
show right now
i'm starting to feel [ __ ] sick i did
too much
i did too much today look at this [ __ ]
this is all bill taking care of himself
now
i'm gonna go right to [ __ ] bed and
i'll be fine in the goddamn morning but
if i go out tonight
it ain't gonna be a good thing right
this is what you do
you don't feel good you [ __ ] cancel
your shows you got a weird-ass [ __ ]
neighbor
uh not going
to be able to make it
tonight
suddenly feeling like i'm getting sick
period not kovid's sick
period just cold sick
all right and then that's it i'm out and
i only said i was gonna do the show
today so nobody was expecting to see me
anyway
okay all right [ __ ] great
okay now i can just finish this podcast
and go to bed
be a smart [ __ ] person for once look
at this bill bill in march taking care
of himself
all right girlfriend has other boyfriend
according to her grandpa
by the way what i just did there is a
really important thing to do for quality
of life
it's something that i just used to plow
through i would get sick all the [ __ ]
time
um all right hey oh billy morrison
uh did you see riders on the storm in
the desert
i've been wanting to take shrooms for
the longest
but i've been too much of a [ __ ] every
time i have the opportunity anyway
anyways he says i'm a 22 year old
college senior from orange county
i've been doing what a guy should be
doing in his college years as far as the
ladies go
spotting red flags right away and
getting out that's good
not getting too emotionally involved and
having fun while also being upfront with
these girls that's the key
if you're just out there having fun let
them know because
according to sydney lauper girls just
want to have fun like they you know
they can be down for something like that
too but you just got to make sure
there's
there's big gaps of time between seeing
them so nobody gets attached
and not trying to [ __ ] them over good
for you i recently met a girl we've been
dating for seven months now
she's awesome and i've never connected
with someone like i do with her well
that's right
that's good because you didn't get
bogged down to a relationship you wait
till somebody special came along
that's what you should do she's smart
funny she's independent
and makes money and her relaxed vibe
matches mine
it's been great and i think i'm finally
starting to grow up
as i've found someone i can see myself
with for the long haul
that's great she's a promo model
and obviously gets a lot of it i thought
you i meant this girl she's a model
you can really see myself with her
that's good dude you got a hottie good
for you and obviously gets a lot of
attention from guys but i trust her
and it doesn't bug me that's good she
has a guy best friend
who used to date one of her girlfriends
kind of strange
wait she has a guy best friend who used
to date one of her girlfriends kind of
strange but i didn't think much of it
they're really close and have been since
high school oh [ __ ] this is the guy
she's gonna marry dude
i have a bad feeling he's in the marine
reserves and lives
right by her they've hung out once or
twice while we've been dating and she's
always been up front about it
and nothing ever seems sketchy
however i want to go meet her gr i went
to go meet her grandfather a couple
weeks ago
massed up obviously and when she
introduced me to him he said ah
so this is the marine guy right she said
no that's aaron my longtime friend
this is zach my boyfriend he then
laughed and said
damn me huh how many boyfriends do you
have then
right away she laughed and told him her
and that guy never dated like that
it's always just been friendly uh when
we left i asked her what the [ __ ] was up
with that
she told me that her grandpa was in the
marines
and he got excited when she told him
that her friend was too
apparently they had never met before the
the guy's over 90 years old so obviously
he's not all there but he's definitely
sharp for his age
after talking to him i tried to brush it
off
and give it time but it's been two weeks
now and i gotta be honest that [ __ ] is
still bugging me
well dude i gotta tell you something if
you were [ __ ] cool with her being hot
and guys looking at her and it didn't
bug you but this bugs you
this is legit you gotta listen to your
gut here
her dog just passed away and i was with
her all day and night when it happened
but as soon as i went back home
she said the guy was gonna come over
cause he was close with the dog too
dude get the [ __ ] out of this
relationship
get out of this relationship i don't
know man i want to believe her because
i've been cheated on before in high
school and this doesn't feel like she's
trying to hide anything
but at the same time that [ __ ] with the
grandpa is tripping me out
what do you think bill am i being
paranoid or should i just brush it off
brush off what happened as an old guy
messing around
or do you think this could be a red flag
well dude if it feels like a red flag
i would address it thank you and i gotta
say your podcast kept me from jumping
out of my 12-story cubicle window
when i had my shitty office job lol go
[ __ ] yourself um
yeah dude uh
i don't know man
i don't like the lay of the land there
at all i'll be honest with you i don't
like the lay of the land and so
i would just uh
uh you got to sit down and talk to her
and just say it bothers you
and well what do you want me to do about
it it's just like well i mean you know
i don't know we've seen this guy all the
[ __ ] i just i don't know i just think
that's [ __ ] weird
there's something [ __ ] weird going on
there there's something
that that whole [ __ ] thing is really
weird she's
the ex-boyfriend
of one of her girlfriends now what i
don't understand
is why didn't she just get with if she
if he was single why the
this is something on your side here why
wouldn't she just get with the guy
i mean is he in the marines marines or
does he do that weekend [ __ ]
you know like how if he's in the [ __ ]
marines why is he around
wouldn't he be deployed somewhere i
don't like it
you know what you know what i'm gonna
[ __ ] i'm gonna phone a friend here
any marines out there what is
what is your gut telling you about this
they're all laughing right now in some
[ __ ] god-forsaken place they're
listening
get the [ __ ] out that's what you're
saying right
over in afghanistan you're listening
right i bet they're saying get the [ __ ]
up dude um
you need to address this you definitely
need to address this
um i don't like it i'm not saying she's
guilty but
there is definitely uh
if this was the cops they would get a
warrant at this point
there's enough here that for a warrant
you might not find anything the alibi
might check out
but this is definitely uh this is
something that
uh perkinioli is up there
um anyway
so uh what else i played with my
daughter today man and my son was
awesome
as always my daughter's still uh
she's getting she's got the bike down as
far as like i just don't have a big
enough driveway
where she can like you know ride around
so i got to take her to the park
it's something i want to do and uh
just do that for like two three days in
a row just let her get it down
or i got to find some place where we can
both go
um you know i just don't like doing it
after she went to school she comes out
of school and she's just like
all right i don't need to learn anything
else i just want to come home have
something to eat
watch bugs bunny or some [ __ ] so i try
to respect that because i loved that
when i was a kid
you know walking home sometimes i used
to take the bus
most times i used to walk and just
joking around with my friends
you know and then getting home
and i grabbed like i'd either make a
steakhum when i was older when i was
younger i'd
have like a powdered doughnut some sort
of shitty [ __ ] food we always had
like twinkies and
hips of 70s right just [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that you know it was so
[ __ ] overrated back then with devil
ducks
you know and every time i'd eat one they
were the driest
yeah you drink like half a gallon of
[ __ ] milk to get those [ __ ] things
down
and um i remember i would come home
and the shows i used to watch was like
there was this in a pretty obscure
cartoon
was on all the time and just it hasn't
gotten any love
over the years it was a show called
deputy dog
hello sheriff the dog and the
deputy dog it was a [ __ ] dog and it
was a deputy
and then the sheriff was an actual
person
and then he was always having problems
with uh
was it morocco mole no what the [ __ ] was
it there was vince
and you know yeah don't go away musky
musky muskrat that's what it was don't
go away mad musky
just go away um
let me see deputy dog i gotta look this
up here before i end the podcast deputy
dog
um deputy dog all right
number of episodes oh there was only 34
episodes
they used to show them all the [ __ ]
time
it aired from 1960 to 1963 deputy dog
first ran weekly september 8 1962
to may 25th 1963 with a brief hiatus in
december
each episode has deputy dog has a deputy
dog cartoon
followed by dingbat and then silly
sydney
i don't remember that the british
television debut
debut on bbc was in 1963.
i just remember deputy dog
deputy dog is a deputy sheriff in
florida
of florida dog and the episode
progressed the location changed to
mississippi
and later to tennessee uh the other
they were like all right we're not south
enough then we went to mississippi this
is this is too far
south let's go in the middle what's the
middle ground of mississippi in florida
tennessee um
that just sounds yes fun name tennessee
just sounds happy
i love that state um one of the most
beautiful [ __ ] states i've ever been
in i [ __ ] love tennessee
the other man the other main characters
are
the varmints musky muskrat
and moley mole possibly possum
tycoon vincent van gopher that's the one
i remember not molly muller remember
vincent van gopher
pig newton and dog's boss sheriff i
don't remember any of those guys
i just remember help deputy dog i'm
sinking in the creek mud
that's all i remember a late addition to
the cast was
astronaut a mischievous alien visitor oh
god that was the end of every cartoon
that's like when the flintstones had
that stupid little green guy
[ __ ] over [ __ ] over
uh much of the comedy's a sight gag
deputy dog later appeared in episodes of
the 1987 series
mighty mouse the new adventures yeah
there's only 34 episodes well i
definitely saw all of those i would come
home and eat nothing but
[ __ ] junk food and i did not want to
do any homework or any [ __ ]
thinking then i would go outside and
play
and then the stress of my homework would
start hitting me like around five i
gotta [ __ ] i gotta do my homework
i remember there was a couple friends i
had that just had to discipline they'd
get off the bus
and be like let's go let's go out and
play let's play you know football
baseball i mean
ride bikes and do some [ __ ] i gotta do
my homework i'd be like [ __ ] that
all right and then they come out around
four o'clock and they'd be done with
their homework and i'd be like
[ __ ] i wish i was them i wish i was them
and that's why i wasn't successful
because back then i put [ __ ] off
but not now not today i think of a [ __ ]
joke i go right over and i write it down
they call in sick to work all right
anyway that's the podcast everybody
i'll let you know how the um
the uh vaccine goes this week we'll see
we'll see if i get it they opened it up
to entertainers
um it'd be funny if they watch my act
yeah
you're not an entertainer you're just a
[ __ ]
angry orange man angry orange men are
not
qualified until uh august all right
yeah okay that's it that's the podcast
sorry don't we need you on to make you
guys tired thank you to everybody that's
been listening thank everybody that
always listens and writes in and all of
that stuff i love hearing from you guys
and uh i don't know i'm feeling you can
feel it man
you can feel it we're turning the corner
all right pete everybody's going to get
this vaccine for the most part right and
then it's just going to be uh we'll get
to go back outside again
you know that'll be it that'll be it
and i've been saying this for a long
time all right
there's a lot of people you're going to
look back fondly on all the time you had
off from not going into work
you know i can tell you
i don't think it's going to be my first
trip back to lax it might be but my
second trip to lax
i might start crying okay
so if you guys see me there crying just
pretend you don't see me
um all right that's it all right go [ __ ]
yourselves and i'll check in on you on
thursday